bonjour gaston est arrivé alors jamais
avant midi il dit que s'il arrive trop
tôt pour objet de faire une sieste et là
c'est la bouleverse tous en composites
en faut pas vous tuer à la tâche n'est
pas prévue et la moins 10 nouveaux
stagiaires il est trop chaud où personne
ne se baladent dans un bureau il a
remplacé l'alarmé anti-incendie parle
alarmes anti bruit presque unique le
bruit c'est le pire ennemi du
travailleur comme tu écris je n'ai pas
qu'il voulait pas tout temps en temps
accepté les rails suivra les procédures
respecter les normes de sécurité la
sécurité c'est rarement sa priorité
enfin faites quelque chose prunelle on
va tout prix pas sex sécu ne peut plus
aller jusqu'à ton café et bien c'est ton
café qui viendra vous présente mon
télésiège on va plus vite sans se
fatiguer on va tous y pas fait un par un
jusqu'au dernier
cette arrivée il ya deux semaines vous
avez déjà deux semaines de retard au
boulot de chez demesmaeker quel plaisir
de vous revoir
[Musique]
c'est mon rêve je vais me réveiller on
n'en parle pas très fait pour contre ce
rapt dormir
non non personne ne s'assoient dans un
resort non
moi